good morning John as make this video
there are lots of people killing lots of
people in France in Paris it is
impossible for me to think about
anything except for that thing and it is
also impossible for me to have any
anything except feelings like there's a
time for analysis there's a time for
thinking is the time for trying to
figure out why people are the way they
are
where behaviors originated but this is
not that time it is just emotions is
just sad fear anger I have a friend
who's in Paris right now he hasn't
tweeted anybody he hasn't done anything
on my social media so it's terrifying it
is just a time for feeling and I know
that we all want to analyse now we need
to live in that kind of world where we
want to immediately take our worldview
and say if only we had been the way we
should have been the way that I wish the
world were this wouldn't have happened
that's going to be flawed forever but it
is especially flawed right now and I
think the thing to feel is what like
whatever it is we should feel like you
know I think if your response is to
disengage that is appropriate if your
response is to stare it live feeds from
Twitter and reddit that is appropriate
if your response is to just be terrified
for your friends your family yourself or
just people because we are all people
that is appropriate there's nothing
useful I could say there's you know like
hatred is not the correct response to
hatred I don't know the world is broken
but hope is not crazy yeah that's good
that was a John Green one it's hard not
to think about the effect this is gonna
have like globally and on your
but I just think like right now I'm I
want to think about the people who risk
their lives to save people and to help
people I want to think about the people
who've lost people and I want to think
about the people who've been lost I
think that's the thing to think about
that's yeah
John I'll see you on Monday